Speaker 1: I want to start today by talking
about a new statement from the CDC about coronavirus
vaccination of younger people and what appears
to be a link to a very rare heart condition,
which can also be caused by the virus itself.
And I think I feel driven to kind of preface
this by saying, on the one hand, I've been
a huge advocate of vaccination and continue
to be and this doesn't change that.
And so for people who will react to me talking
about this by saying, are you going anti vaccine?
Absolutely not.
The risks of this condition with the vaccine
are far lower than the risks of the very same
condition.
If you get covid.
On the other hand, for people who have been
saying, David, you won't ever talk about the
side effects of vaccines.
Well, you're also wrong because I'm talking
about them right here.
So let's get right into it.
CDC safety group says there is a likely link
between rare heart inflammation in young people
after covid shot.
There have been more than 12 hundred cases
of a myocarditis or pericarditis, mostly in
30 and under people who received Fyssas or
Moderne as covid-19 vaccine.
According to CDC data, roughly 300 million
shots had been administered as of June 11th.
For both vaccines combined, there were 12
heart inflammation cases per million doses.
The CDC safety group is calling it a likely
association between this rare heart inflammatory
condition in adolescents and young adults,
mostly after they've received their second
shot based on the most recent data available.
Twelve hundred cases, according to a series
of presentations published yesterday Wednesday.
Myocarditis is the inflammation of the heart
muscle.
Pericarditis is the inflammation of the membrane
surrounding the heart.
Doctor Grassley chairs the CDC safety group,
says, quote, Clinical presentation of myocarditis.
Cases following vaccination has been distinct,
occurring most often within one week after
dose two with chest pain as the most common
presentation, information is being gathered
about how to manage this, the agency said
there have been two hundred and sixty seven
cases of myocarditis or pericarditis after
one dose and eight hundred and twenty seven
after two doses, one hundred and thirty two
additional cases where doses received is unknown.
Importantly, Dr. Tom Shimabukuro says this
is still a rare event.
It's mostly men under 30.
Remember, the blood clotting with the JMJ
was mostly women under 45.
This is mostly men under 30.
Very important of the two hundred and ninety
five people who developed the condition and
have been discharged.
Seventy nine percent fully recovered, nine
were hospitalized, two in intensive care.
So there's no reason to hide this.
We want to understand the risks and understand
any medication, treatment or whatever that
that we are obtaining.
When you look at these numbers, you're talking
about two out of three hundred million doses
to people in intensive care.
And so we should be aware of this as vaccination
sites are told about this and develop protocol
for managing it.
This is why you have all of this data and
do this research.
The vaccine is still way safer at all ages
than getting covid.
That's an important thing to remember.
We now know I know personally of people of
a variety of ages.
Twenty five plus dying of covid.
I know of one person with an allergic reaction
to the vaccine.
That was sort of serious.
She was brought to the E.R. and was fine after
a couple of hours.
There's no reason to hide this stuff.
It looks bad to hide it.
It should be reported in proper context.
And remember that covid itself comes with
risk of heart inflammation, and it's a really
important thing to remember.
So information is still being gathered about
this.
It's extraordinarily rare.
And even in almost all cases where this rare
thing happens, people make a full recovery.
Those are the facts as we understand them
right now.
And as more information comes forward about
this, of course, I will present it to you.